So now we can come
to the central topic
of our lecture, which describes
the conditions under which
a Markov chain
reaches steady state.
The question that we
are asking, and which
we motivated in the
previous lecture
by looking at an example with a
simple, two-state Markov chain
is the following-- we are
asking whether the probability
of being in state j at time n,
given that you started at time
0 in state i, converges
to some constant, pi of j.
In fact, that question
consists of two parts.
Do we have convergence?
And is it independent of i?
We have seen an example where
it is not always the case.
For example, in
this Markov chain,
you have two recurrent classes.
This is one current class here.
And then there's a second
recurrent class here.
And we know that if
we are interested
in the long-time probability of
being in that state, assuming
that you started in one
of these states here,
the probability will
be 0 to be here.
But if you started in
one of these two states,
the probability
would be positive.
So clearly here, the
initial conditions
will matter whenever you have
two or more recurrent classes.
So what would happen if you
have only one recurrent class?
So let's remove this one and
consider this situation here,
where you have only
one recurrent class.
In that case, what
we have seen--
this is still not sufficient.
Indeed, if you look at
this recurrent class
and you are interested
in 9 and assume
that you started at
9, then at time 1,
you will be either here or here.
And at time 2, you will
be back at 9 for sure.
And in general, for time n even,
the probability will be one,
and for time n odd,
it will be zero.
So that specific n-step
transition probability
in that situation here
will never converge.
It will keep oscillating
between 0 and 1.
So the issue here is that we
had a periodic recurrent class,
and the period in
that case was 2.
So let us consider now
the final case where
you have only one
recurrent class.
And that recurrent
class is not periodic.
And how do we realize that
this is not periodic here?
Well, we have a self
transition here.
So now that we have
one recurrent class,
and this recurrent class is
aperiodic, the question is--
do you have this kind
of convergence here?
And it turns out-- and this is
the big theory of Markov chains
under the name of the
steady-state convergence
theorem-- that indeed, yes.
The rij's do converge to a
steady-state limit, which
we call a steady-state
probability as
long as these two
conditions are satisfied.
So in summary, not only
these two conditions
are necessary, like we had
seen with our counter example,
but they are sufficient.
We're not going to
prove this theorem here.
It's a little bit complicated.
But what is the intuitive
idea behind this theorem?
Well, let us think
intuitively as
to why the initial
state does not matter,
when the chain has
a single recurrent
class and no periodic states.
The technique is
pretty classical.
The idea is the
following-- think
about two independent
copies of that Markov chain,
starting at two different
initial conditions.
So for example, think
about a red copy.
And the red copy would
initially start at state 2.
And then at each unit of time
will jump to the next state,
according to the transition
probabilities of this Markov
chain.
So for example, so this is
at time 0, which was here.
Time 1 might come here.
Time 2, 3, 4, 5 and so forth.
So this is one copy
of the Markov chain.
So think about another
copy, the blue copy.
And assume that the blue
copy started here at time 0.
And again, independently
of the other,
but during the
same unit of time,
it will jump from state
to state according
to the transition
probabilities again.
So think that maybe
this one will go here.
Then will go here.
Times 2, 3 will be here,
4 here, maybe 5 here.
And so forth.
Now look at these two
independent copies.
There will be a time and in that
case, for our little example
here, is the time 4,
where for the first time
they collide, in
the sense that they
jump to the same state
at the same time.
So at time 4, both
of them are here.
Now, think a little bit
about the future evolution
of these two independent copies,
given that they are in state 4
now.
And here we are using
the Markov property
to say that the future
evolution of the blue copy
is independent of
the previous path.
Given that you are in state 4,
the fact that you started in 1
does not matter for the future
evolution of that blue copy.
And for the red copy,
given that you are in 4,
the fact that you
started in 2 does not
matter to characterize
the future evolutions
of that red copy.
So in some sense,
probabilistically speaking,
these two copies cannot be
distinguished for their future
evolutions, given that
they both are at state 4.
So this means that the initial
conditions for these two
copies, given that these two
copies met at a given state,
at a given time--
probabilistically speaking,
nothing can differentiate
them in the future because
of the Markov property.
That's essentially the
high-level idea of this proof.
Now, the key thing
here mathematically
is to prove that whenever
you have a Markov chain that
has a single recurrent class and
this single recurrent class is
not periodic, and you start
from any initial conditions,
the two copies will
eventually meet in a given
state at a given time
with probability 1.
OK.
So now let's assume
that the theorem holds.
That means that
yes, indeed, we have
proved the existence of these
steady-state probabilities.
The question is now
how to calculate them.
Well, the way to do it is to
start from our key recursion
that we had for the m-state
transition probabilities.
So where we assume
here that we have m
states, and we are
going to take the limits
on both sides of this equality.
So when n goes to infinity,
we know that rij of n
will go to pi of j.
And here, when n
goes to infinity,
in some sense n minus 1
also goes to infinity.
And so rik of n minus
1 should go to pi of k.
And so we are using
that property.
And again, we take the
limit as n goes to infinity.
And we say that rij of
n converges to here.
Now, the limit on
this side-- you
have a limit of a finite sum.
You can exchange the
summation and the limit.
And so you take
the limit inside.
The limit of rik of n minus
1, when n goes to infinity,
goes to pi of k.
And then you have
the resulting term.
And so from that,
taking the limit
again as n goes to
infinity on both sides,
you end up with this
equation here for j.
Now, you can do that for any
of the j of your Markov chain.
So you have m states, so you
end up having m equations.
And you have m
unknowns, the m pi j's.
So this is a system of m
equations with m unknowns.
Unfortunately, this
system is singular
and it has multiple solutions.
And one way to see that
is the solution pi j
equals 0 for all j is a
valid solution to the system.
Zero equals zero.
So clearly this is
not very informative.
So maybe we need
one more condition
to get a uniquely solvable
system of linear equations.
It turns out that the
system of equations
has a unique solution if you
impose an additional condition,
which is pretty natural,
which means that the pi
j's are actually probabilities.
They should all sum to 1.
In other words, in
the future, if you
ask yourself what is the
probability of being in state
j, and you get pi
of j, the summation
of all of the possible
states have to be 1.
If you consider that additional
equation, plus that system
here, so if you consider
this extended system,
then you can show that
this has a unique solution.
And this unique solution
cannot be this one.
And so in conclusion,
we can find
the steady-state probabilities
of the Markov chain
by just solving these
linear equations, which
should be numerically a
straightforward procedure.